bevor es losgeht nimmst du denn auch
schon an meinem facebook gewinnspiel
teil ich habe jetzt neue facebook seite
und an den ersten 25.000 likes hatten
sich dieser wert vier erzeugt und toller
ein paar spielen deswegen check die
facebook-seite ab ganz oben erster denke
der beschreibung jetzt viel spaß mit
diesem video und ja lasst es erstmal ein
bisschen aufrecht wirken bis zu meinem
anbieter besser wieder raus leute was
geht ab seite richtig leise sprechen
also gerade laut reden ich bin halt nach
draußen unterwegs und es ist einfach
schon irgendwie halb zwölf oder so und
ich habe heute richtig richtig heftiges
vor
dafür konnte sofort eigentlich schon mal
20.000 mindestens da lassen und zwar
suchen wir jetzt eine haus wo er einfach
reingehen und die nächsten 24 stunden
drin bleiben
das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen 24
stunden einfach und dafür am besten gar
nicht erwischen lassen
zu spät
fällt hier rein sein
okay noch mal glück gehabt altern ab das
war richtig knapp
achso und übrigens ich habe endlich mal
wieder meine cap wieder
aber das ist jetzt auch egal okay wir
suchen jetzt einfach heraus ich glaube
ich habe eins gefunden
das ist auf keinen fall jetzt auf jeden
fall nicht los geht das ist 100 prozent
auf exakt da kommt noch was mich
versteckt 30.000 1 merken okay es war
richtig knapp
also auf jeden fall was mache ich hier
ok jetzt die tür ein
wir brauchen schlüssel aber sehr sehr
viele versteckt ihr einfach den
schlüssel und der matratze deswegen auch
nikos mutter ist dass das vertrauen zur
glück
nicht um die sind zwar polizei war
polizei alter schützt das war knapp
ehrlich wie dumm kann man so einfach
sein schüssel darunter tun
also wie gesagt auch viel fall nicht
mein haus ich muss ich muss jetzt leise
sein
es ist gerade 23 uhr 30 wohnheims and no
fähig
ok 50.000 mache ich das nochmal
denke
ich hoffe es ist keine scheiße da brennt
licht sagt man
hallo hallo
gelder fernseher
ich glaube ich erstmal fernsehen ist ein
sofa knochen sofa recht schön jetzt
einfach mal hin
das müsst ihr euch einfach mal geben ich
bin einfach um halb zwölf in einem
fremden haus was nicht mir gehört um
halb zwölf einfach so auf dem sofa
schilde vor der hausbesitzer kommen elf
die polizei rufen für glock eine anzeige
wegen hausfriedensbruch aber gibt
einfach einen daumen nach oben bei
50.000 gleich passiert das glaube ich
nicht
also gut obwohl ist mir auch egal wenn
ich 50.000 auf dieses video habe dann
nämlich so genau anzeigen kauf weiter
gebt euch das mal 50.000 gleich seite
wir gucken jetzt einfach fernsehen
walter ich gucke rad einfach in einem
fremden aufs fernsehen leute gebt euch
dass ich guck in einem fremden haus
fernsehen dafür auf jeden fall nochmal
jetzt allen kommentare heftig ich bin
schreibt auf jeden fall jetzt an die
kommentare heftig alex wie es der
heftigste
ich hab jetzt einfach mal das licht
angemacht weil ich habe mega hunger ich
bin jetzt bestimmt schon zwei drei
stunden hier
wir haben jetzt mittlerweile wo ist mein
handy der mittlerweile 23 57 also ich
bin schon 23 34 57 drei stunden drei
stunden 27 bin ich jetzt in diesem
fremden haus sind und ich hab so mega
hunger weinmarkt richtig wenn ihr das
mal gucken ob dieser ofen auch
funktioniert in diesem haus aber
angebracht sein land diese pläne für die
coachings gans war hier immer möglich
okay leute meine kartoffeln fährt sieht
jetzt so aus vor lecker
das müsst ihr euch das mal vorstellen
ich es einfach gerade auf die kosten von
anderer leute die diese kartoffeln
gekauft haben die habe ich jetzt eiskalt
hier in diesem fremden haus gekocht
richtig krass oder
wir sehen uns gleich gleich passiert
noch was richtig heftiges
ich glaube dir hier in diesem zimmer
stellt das erkannt da
der lenker ist
ich muss hier nur kurz im abgeber peter
besser wieder raus
richtig sei nicht dass leute
wir müssen jetzt abbauen er fischt
wer mit einer 2 ich weiß nicht 24
stunden im haus
ja also das was mit diesem video ich
hoffe natürlich erst hat euch ein
bisschen unterhalten
ihr habt wahrscheinlich gemerkt wenn ich
es nicht gemerkt hab dann geht man zum
arzt so auf jeden fall war das alles
ironie das war eine parodie auf diese
ganzen 24 schon videos ich hoffe es hat
euch unterhalten und ich hatte ein
bisschen schwach ansehen
wenn das der fall ist kann dann nach
oben verlassen ansonsten sehen wir uns
morgen denkt mal wieder 1 1 nur zu einem
neuen video ich habe jetzt endlich mal
zwischen video gesagt und ich wünschen
noch einen schönen tag kommt rein
ciao und checkt die facebook seite 3